Sẵn ngày mà chỉ nếu mời thông dở đi phương,
sếu bảo Melissa đã đổ bộ và khu vực nguyên tri về rí có tình,
sâm tri ở gồn được của ba,
bối sức só suy chi một trong tri mấy năm 2020 trên dở
chở thành bảo cấp ba cực kinh quý dệm,
theo thang Staffield Simpsons.
Chúng ta bảo của Xam I, cảnh bảo,
bảo sẽ tích tụng dị truyền qua mìn đông năng ngàn của ba,
gây xam ngờ lớn chụi cường.
Và gây người cơ lũ khói chỉ dự dạo,
chứ đó bảo Melissa đã tàn phát cho mai khác,
với sức gió đá tới ba trong kilomét trình dở
khiến nhất bán người thiệt mạc,
cùng nhiều vùng nông nghiệp trong liền đã bị phá hội.
Chính phục của ba đã sử tàn hơn bẩy trong nghìn người tại nắm tình,
các niệm trong khi liên nông của hình chương vận chuyển hàng cú trở,
tới các khu vực truyển hồn.
Các chuyển giá khi hộ nhìn đình,
Melissa là một trong những cân bảo mạnh nhất từng xuất hiện ở khu vực cari bây,
sâm ngàn, hoặc vượt sau với các xíu bảo lịch sử,
như khá truyên nè, năng mang in không cho lệ năng.
Mariana màn in không cho bây,
hai hà vi, năng mang in không cho bây,
phản nắng suường báo nè, càng giữ rồi,
ra bến được hiểu tàn cầu.